I will say that is one thing I really
admire about Star Wars is that it's set
in the past because all other sci-fi is
set in the future
why is sci-fi fantasy better than all of
their genres wow
um
so this is like extremely my subjective
personal opinion because I know there's
people out there like my mother who are
like I hate sci-fi she hates sci-fi and
fantasy like any time I'm like let's try
this show it's so far
um she gets so upset because she's like
it's not relatable to me personally I
like the genre the best because it's a
way of handling serious subject matter
without being preachy
um especially sci-fi you know you get to
like Drop people into a fictitious world
that is critiquing the way our real life
Society might be
acting behind the scenes but in a little
bit more like I'm thinking like squid
game right squid game to me is like
sci-fi for sure
um Slow Burn sci-fi spoiler alert sorry
everybody but um definitely
like a game where everyone is kind of
killing each other but it's a more
brutal version than like The Hunger
Games that's that's a commentary on how
our system pits us against each other
again going back to that competitiveness
going back to that form of capitalism
um
sci-fi and fantasy allow you to say okay
I don't have to think about my daily
life
you get to just enjoy this fun story
but behind the scenes of the story is
this little like hey maybe think about
this incepting your mind and then you're
like that's relatable hmm let me think
about that why why is this movie
bringing up these strong emotions why is
this book bringing up these feelings in
me
um I mean I really do think that a lot
of genre is about taking a break from
our day-to-day world even comedy right
comedy may look like our world it's just
that the stakes are like stupidly high
right like I'm like the toast wasn't bad
and people are like aha that's such a
silly way to act but like
yeah no one really rarely do people do
that in life and if you saw it in real
life it would probably scare the Jesus
out of you because you're like why are
you having such a big feeling all of
those different genres allow us to
escape and when we've escaped our world
people are more open-minded to actually
think critically about our world
do you think sci-fi gets the respect it
deserves
uh this is probably an example of me
living in a bit of a bubble because I I
interact with a lot of people who like
sci-fi and they're all like yeah sci-fi
is great so
you know I probably can't comment
objectively but
um I would hope it does I mean I think
you know just thinking especially out of
the past decade like or in the past 100
years like things that have come and
gone there's
um
there's sci-fi that have greatly
influenced the people
you know stuff that stayed in our public
conscious there's there's quotes that
are misattributed to people that come
from sci-fi so
yeah I would say it's doing great as a
genre
what are some tropes that we want to see
in a sci-fi film
boy it's interesting you know I feel
like in the past
decade and a half
um every sci-fi movie is starring a
heroine these days which I love like
seeing strong female characters like
yeah I love this
um but it almost is like tropey to the I
mean I would say the tropes are just
like a lot of the beats in the story
um
it's fine I was talking to no offense to
Star Wars I love Star Wars a lot but
Star Wars comes to mind I was talking to
somebody about it recently and how um
you know with Star Wars it's like almost
every single IP is now like the rebels
are rebelling right and I'm like I feel
like we're in a galaxy and we've seen
that story and I I think there's more to
this galaxy than the rebels are
rebelling right like I want to see a
story that is not about that or like I
was I had this crazy pitch which um you
know someone go steal this pitch please
I'm like what if you had a cooking show
right and it's like hey we're gonna
learn different like recipes from the
Galaxy and it's like an obviously alien
person like teaching you these things
and it's stuff that you can make at home
because you're a Star Wars fan and
you're watching it but in the background
of the show you can tell that like a
rebellion is starting and then towards
the end you almost have like a fourth
wall break and a total genre shift as
you're dropped into another Universe
like that would be something like what
Wanda Vision did which I'm gonna just
say one division is sci-fi I'm making
that claim now
um I loved one division I'm not the
biggest Marvel person but that one
really was like whoa for me because
they took the tropes out they they
boldly told the story that I have not
seen told before which is interesting
because when you think about like sci-fi
literature there's really weird stuff
out there right like there's um
Tender Is the flesh is an example of a
story where it's like oh my God that's a
horrifying universe that I never want to
think about
um or I have no mouth but I must scream
right like sci-fi literature is so
original to the point of like where did
your mind come up with this like I
wondered what are you working through
that now I am being subjected to this
but for some reason in film we kind of
lean on the same tropes of like well I'm
just a girl living in this world it's
kind of janky and I'm being subjected to
the injustices of the system and oh my
God I found myself I don't want to be a
hero I'm just a normal girl I am Leading
the People I feel like I have seen this
movie so many times recently
um it is the backbone of so much film
sci-fi and again I'm like some other
stories out there and I want to keep
seeing strong female characters I want
to keep seeing a lot of the cool
um kind of more inclusionary stuff that
we're seeing in modern sci-fi I feel
like the story beats could have a
refresh and people would be like thank
you I don't need another superhero film
I'm sorry for everybody who loves them
I'm like what if we didn't do that we
told a different story in that universe
you know I like the cooking idea by the
way thank you that'd be really cool it'd
be really fun and it would be it would
be able to touch like it would it would
be super Niche but I think in a way that
would attract more fans
they would get one thing out of it and
then it would be like genre break and
then all of a sudden it ends in a
different way also letting shows end
that's a nice thing like being like
we've gotten to the end
we're not making another seat it's the
end the mini series is a great vehicle
that I think we should all Embrace more
you know is there one series that you
wish didn't end
ooh that's a good question
yeah you know what I'm gonna say it I
deeply love the show Merlin I think a
lot of people find it to be like
extremely corny if you haven't seen it
highly recommend it it was a BBC show it
feels like originally it was branded for
children or like young adults it's
lovely I am so sad that it ended I think
it really the character arcs were so
compelling because everybody is aged
down like Arthur and Merlin and Morgana
and what's her face the gwenevere are
all like really young and are all just
people who are existing and you know
what their big story beats are gonna be
but you can see how like they subvert it
I think it's just it's a really
brilliantly crafted show and I'm very
sad that it ended
I didn't want it to end
which sci-fi movie made you fall in love
with the genre
in question
oh no what made me fall in love with the
genre
I have to okay now we have to think back
to Baby Sheila and I'm
I know I it's really actually hard for
me to say what is the first sci-fi that
I encountered
I know it's one of those things or just
because of like the content that my
father likes it's just it was always
around me sci-fi and fantasy you know
and then of course there's Disney and so
did growing up as Disney child
um I
it was always around me but in terms of
like the first time that I was like oh
this genre
you know it was when the
post-apocalyptic thing really kicked off
um and there was it's like the Hunger
Games did really well and all of a
sudden there was all of this like why a
literature where it's like we're in love
and America's burning and it was like
this whole thing
um
I don't know it's just like the first I
I remember
I don't remember which book it was but I
just I remember seeing a book or seeing
a film and being like whoa that's a
really different way to think about the
world and there's like a specificity
that the Sci-Fi genre uses that other
people don't use and then I remember
starting to see Indie sci-fi and how it
really reflected sort of like the darker
aspects of sci-fi that you see
traditionally in literature and that's
when I really was like this is you know
like for especially for filmmaking and
Indie filmmaking like low budget High
concept stuff where it's like wow I am
extremely disturbed by the story that
I've just experienced but it's getting
me to think about things that I would
never think about otherwise so that's
when like I guess
in young adulthood and adulthood is when
it really like I caught the bug and
started to really see
[Music]
um
the value of it
thinking critically about what our
future could look like you know I will
say that is one thing I really admire
about Star Wars is that it's set in the
past because all other sci-fi is set in
the future
so the day that I realized Star Wars was
set in the past was the day that my mind
exploded I didn't realize that it was in
the past
but yeah I am I Star Wars I actually
didn't see until a couple years ago that
was something that I came into in my
adulthood but
[Music]
um
I couldn't even I literally couldn't
even tell you what's the thing that set
it off it's just
I started thinking critically about what
I was watching and it got me excited
I know I really am affected by a film or
literature or art when I like really
fixated and just want to talk about it
all the time but I'm like huh
interesting this has had an effect on me
um and
yeah I guess like going to Conservatory
in New York I was exposed to a lot of
unique ways of telling stories
and I know that that was and that was
probably where everything connected
now you got me on memory lane